fired Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson is coming back he is relaunching
his show
on Twitter what the hell would Twitter
what does that make any I don't know
here is Tucker Carlson's announcement
now viewed nearly 20 million times he
made the announcement on Twitter I guess
partnering with Elon Musk to relaunch
telling a number of corrosive lies let's
take a look at Tucker's big announcement
filmed in Ultra wide screen they've
never seen widescreen this wide
um apparently from his cabin in Maine or
Florida who knows let's take a listen
hey it's Tucker Carlson you often hear
people say the news is full of lies but
most of the time that's not exactly
right much of what you see on television
or read the New York Times is in fact
true in the literal sense it could pass
one of the media's own fact checks
lawyers would be willing to sign off on
it in fact they may have but that
doesn't make it true it's not true at
the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie a lie of the
stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated how does that
work let's see if I tell you that a man
has been unjustly arrested for armed
robbery that is not strictly speaking a
lie he may have been framed at this
point there's been no trial so no one
can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not I'm misleading
you and that's what the news media are
doing and what's really funny about this
is that it's a very fair criticism
of the way that Fox News including
Tucker Carlson present news stories and
have done so since they launched in what
it was in 1996 or 1997. it's quite I
mean he's right about everything he's
saying the problem is he's as guilty as
anyone of exactly what he's calling out
here every story that matters every day
of the week every week of the year
what's it like to work in a system like
that after more than 30 years in the
middle of it we could tell you stories
what a victim huh what a poor guy the
best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it so
now Tucker is arguing he was fired for
bumping up against the limits valiantly
and bravely trying to tell us the truth
but I guess someone didn't really want
him to do that or something I mean this
you could only believe this if you
followed absolutely nothing of what's
been going on with Tucker Carlson for
the last decade that's not a guess it's
guaranteed every person who works in
English language media understands that
the rule of what you can't say defines
everything it's filthy really right and
it's utterly corrupting you can't have a
free Society if people aren't allowed to
say what they think is true speech is
the fundamental prerequisite for
democracy that's why it's enshrined in
the first of our constitutional
amendments
amazingly as of tonight there aren't
many platforms left that allow free
speed there aren't that's surprising to
many people last a big one remaining in
the world the only one is Twitter how
can we are now wow Twitter has long
served as the place where our national
conversation incubates and develops
Twitter is not a partisan site
everybody's allowed here and we think
that's a good thing
and yet for them who's this we by the
way most part the news that you see
analyzed on Twitter comes from media
organizations that are themselves thinly
disguised propaganda Outlets like Fox
you see it on cable news you talk about
it on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge
we think that's a bad system we know
exactly how it works and we're sick of
it starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon there
you go so Tucker Carlson bravely
announcing that he will be coming to
Twitter now I will mention that Elon
Musk in response to this uh tweeted
um I want to be clear we have not signed
a deal of any kind whatsoever Tucker is
subject to the same rules and rewards of
all content creators rewards means
subscriptions and AD Revenue share still
working on software needed for ladder
which is a function of how many people
subscribe and the ad views associated
with the content I hope that many others
particularly from the left also choose
to be content creators on this platform
listen I'd love to learn more about that
I we we've never been there's never been
ad Revenue available to us that we've
been aware of on Twitter which is
interesting I'd like to learn more so
listen this is Tucker's big return
I don't know to what extent this is the
most profitable Avenue for him I I just
don't know I need to learn a little more
about it uh but it it is very clear that
this is the continued uh refrain from
the right that pre-elon musk Twitter was
not for free speech it was not a
so-called Free Speech platform the
speech of conservatives was unfairly
limited but now we can all rejoice and
pray at the altar of Elon Musk because
he has saved Twitter made it a free
speech platform once again now when you
look at that algorithmic for you feed on
Twitter you very quickly realize that it
has overwhelmingly become a platform
that feeds you right-wing dribble uh
from some of the folks I mentioned when
we talked about this on the Lex Friedman
podcasting including Bridget Gabriel and
others for some reason I always have
shown her stuff even though I don't
follow her so this is Tucker's big
announcement I'm interested did from a
media critique perspective of seeing how
it goes I'm interested in seeing whether
people do shows on Twitter which is sort
of A New Concept and we're going to
follow it make sure you're subscribed on
the platforms that uh we have not
um abandoned uh at this point in time
which include of course YouTube Tick
Tock Snapchat and many many others we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
people often ask me about my daily
routine you know I'm interviewed about
the David packman show how did you do it
how do you do this and like daily
routine just often comes up and how do
you stay healthy and of course I talk
about exercise and I talk about eating
the right diet but one of the things
that can happen if you are not eating
the right diet or you're traveling or
life gets in the way is you end up with
some kind of vitamin deficiency a daily
scoop of ag1 from our sponsor athletic
greens makes this super easy to take off
of your list of things to worry about
one scoop of ag1 you get the entire
day's worth of 75 high quality vitamins
and minerals from Whole Food sourced
ingredients ag-1 is cheaper than dealing
with a bunch of different supplements
it's infinitely more convenient you just
take a scoop before you have your coffee
for example as I do in the morning and
you're covered for the entire day many
of my friends love ag1 any anyone I
mention it to seems to get hooked when I
go on vacation I bring the ag1 travel
packs with me especially because I'm not
always eating the same diet when I'm
traveling that I do at home staying
properly nourished so important to
feeling your best ag1 just makes it
really easy and very convenient go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman to get a free
year supply of vitamin D I've talked
about vitamin D so many times plus five
free ag1 travel packs the link is down
below